Irán y Arabia Saudita podrían estar
iniciando una nueva era tras años de
rivalidad impulsan su acercamiento con
la reapertura de la embajada de iraní en
riad es una fase clave en un proceso que
iniciaron en marzo con la mediación de
China las uní Arabia Saudita rompió
relaciones con la Irán en 2016 tras un
ataque a su embajada en Teherán que
siguió a la ejecución de un clérigo chií
por las autoridades del reino Es
probable que un acercamiento entre las
potencias rivales tenga repercusiones
importantes en toda la región Empezando
por países como yemen iraki Líbano
podríamos vernos solo una apaciguamiento
y calma de la situación de conflictos o
Guerras en la región sino también
seguridad y protección de los envíos y
suministros energéticos procedentes del
Golfo Pérsico
aún no se ha fijado fecha de reapertura
de la embajada Saudita en Teherán por
ahora el reino recibe al secretario de
estado estadounidense Anthony blinken un
día antes de partir hacia ria d blinken
expresó su preocupación por Irán desde
un lugar simbólico
seguimos creyendo que la diplomacia es
la mejor manera de impedir de manera
verificable eficaz y sostenible que Irán
obtenga un arma nuclear seguirán rechaza
la vía de la diplomacia como el
presidente biden ha dejado Claro en
repetidas ocasiones todas las opciones
están sobre la mesa para evitar que Irán
consiga un arma nuclear
Estados Unidos considera a Irán como una
amenaza para su Aliado Israel el
secretario de estado animó al reino a
normalizar sus relaciones con tel aviv